the warm waters of the Atlantic Ocean
the flying fish giving every impression
of an aquatic world teeming with life
but below the surface the Seas are in
trouble and the scientists on board this
ship are trying to find out why I joined
them for a dive into the depth ten miles
off Bermuda it's a plunge into another
world
the bubbles clear the light fades the
submarines silhouetted against the ocean
blue 60 meters down we reached the
seabed
so I'll translate a little bit over to
you but to a pilot who's cooked up
molten a thousand dives it's not looking
good one of the things that that I've
seen is you know more and more of this
kind of
almost looks like smothering of of the
wreath on the top and I think that's
probably from you know sewage and
run off the nekton mission is the most
comprehensive ever ocean health check
the scientists are looking at everything
from water chemistry and biodiversity to
the impact of the lionfish a gluttonous
predator spread into the Atlantic by
human activity
divers follow lines across the sea
bottom recording everything with
high-resolution cameras samples are
collected to be analyzed back on the
surface
coral reefs are the brain forests of the
sea 25% of all marine species live
around here that's 800,000 and all and
that is why coral is such a good
indicator of ocean health the missions
chief scientist is in another submarine
diving to 150 metres the corals are
largely healthy small fish are abundant
but the larger species are almost absent
back in his lab on board the ship he
gives his assessment it's down to
overfishing when you seriously over
exploit marine ecosystems it can take
them decades to recover and that's
that's in shallow water you can imagine
what happens if you drag I say a cruel
tray of deep-sea coral beds you know
that is going to take hundreds of years
the varied and expansive corals here are
also under threat the seals are warming
and becoming more acidic climate change
again human activity stressing if not
killing the reefs the team here say we
need to act now
oh we know that the deep ocean is
changing its fastest rate for millions
and millions of years well we don't
really understand at the moment is its
health and its resilience we need far
more missions like this and that's one
of the problems trillions are being
spent going into outer space and hardly
any money is being spent going into
inner space into the deep ocean despite
how critical is for Humanity the oceans
of the planets lungs and larder half our
oxygen comes from below the waves and
fish feed more than a billion people but
for how much longer
Thomas More Sky News Bermuda